you're Gary Vee it's lee Malone hear
from you got this bro first of all on
behalf of myself and the motivators here
you've got this bro thank you so much
but will your teachings all your books
all your videos you are the man there's
no doubt about it love your stuff man my
question is really simple we speak a lot
in schools colleges universities we have
messages that we want to give out we
want to help teach these kids bring them
to a better place help them become a
better version of themselves but the
problem is is for all the following that
we've built up from all the people on
Twitter and Instagram and YouTube and
stuff like that a lot of the schools
don't really care about that stuff so my
question is how do I convey what
following is to people in schools head
teachers lecturers professors how do I
convey that to someone who just doesn't
care about that stuff thanks man would
really appreciate it out peace peace
don't edit any of that let the whole
thing run um I love this question I
spent no time convincing people to
believe in what I believe in I've been
coming whines the internet itself back
in 97 google adwords in two thousand
email marketing in 97 social today
snapchat two years ago I have no virtual
reality oculus rift in a couple years I
have no interest in convincing anybody
about myself so mate here's the mistake
you're making that so many make they're
wasting good time and energy trying to
commence while taking that same time and
allocating it to reaching more people
you need to reach out to every single
school professor and organization in the
world or your region or where you want
to play all of them find the 18 that are
intrigued and spend your time there
versus one by one spending a week a
month a year trying to convince this
person and then nothing happens don't
try to convert the unconverted ball i'm
thrilled that they don't get it make fun
of them after you're done in a couple
years and say mate remember when you
didn't get it you're an idiot that's fun
I love doing that and that's what you
need to do so take all your time because
that's the asset for all of you
listening here and notice them notice in
the comment section I'm trying to give
answers that helps anybody no matter
what they do even though these are
specific questions that is the talent I
have as a storyteller this is a big one
the time that you have that is the asset
the only one there's not more of it's
the big one and apply it to places where
there's fertile grounds go reach out to
more grounds to find out which ones are
fertile versus trying to convert a
non-fertile one into a fertile one